Are there any issues with adding Fend-Bend-Dissol protocol to my current Supplement Protocol?
Typically, there's no issues if a person wanted to add Fend-Bend-Dissol to their protocol,
or if they wanted to add Ivermectin to their protocol, except that which we've talked about in the past,
you'd want to get a complete metabolic panel done on a more regular basis.
So, you want to look at both your liver markers and your kidney markers,
because now you're taking a drug. So, it's not a very high dose if Fend-Bend-Dissol is to dose
that a 10-pound dog would take. Still, it's a drug. It's a medication that can be difficult
for your liver to process. So, a lot of people that have liver issues, or if you have genetic issues
with your liver, you don't process certain drugs very well, and it can cause an elevation
of your AST, ALT, and alkaline phosphatase. So, you want to look at those. You can have issues with
your kidney markers as well. So, you want to make sure that you're keeping an eye on that.
So, as long as you are willing to get more regular blood work, or what's more regular,
well, get some blood work before you start that, so we can see a baseline of those markers,
and maybe then a month in after doing that protocol, or if you're having any increased symptoms
of like pain in your liver or anything, get another blood test to make sure you don't have a spike
of those markers. So, if you could keep those markers within balance, don't see any problem
in adding those therapies to your current protocol. So, if the question is, is Fend-Bend-Dissol
or Iverback could negatively affect the supplements I'm taking, the answer would be no.
So, in that sense, there's no issue with adding those. Their only issue is that it could affect
your liver, so you want to make sure you keep an eye on that.